an update now on a bizarre Scandal
surrounding Long Island Congressman
elect George Santos a New York Times
investigation suggests he fabricated
parts of his life story including his
education his work history and even his
ethnic background the New York State
Attorney General's office is now looking
into this Santos tweeted yesterday I
have my story to tell and it will be
told next week Caitlin Huey Burns has
more
the congressman elect is pledging to
give answers for the first time since
the allegations surfaced and there is no
shortage of questions I think people
just want professionals Santos claimed
to have worked for Goldman Sachs and
Citigroup something he spoke about
during a 2020 interview with CBS when I
first started in my career at Citigroup
I was told oh you're a really smart guy
but representatives from the firms tell
CBS news they could not confirm his
employment Santos said he earned an
undergraduate degree from Baruch College
but a spokesperson says they could not
find a match a representative from NYU
where he claimed to have earned an MBA
also said they had no record of him and
the Internal Revenue Service has no
public record of an animal rescue
charity he claimed to have owned with
tax-exempt status or no stranger to
persecution my grandfather fleeing to
Ukraine in 1920s to Belgium then fleeing
Belgium to Brazil in 1940 it's a story
of survival of tenacity of grit as we
like to call it now the Jewish
publication the forward Found Records
contradicting Santos's claims that his
grandparents fled the Holocaust and
despite his current claims of wealth CBS
News spoke to the pastor of Saint Rita's
Catholic Church in Long Island City who
said in 2016 when Santos's mother died
Santos said the family could not afford
a funeral and asked for assistance do
you like what you see this year Santos
helped Republicans win a narrow majority
in the midterm election by flipping a
democratic seat in a debate he had sharp
words for his Democratic opponent Robert
Zimmerman do you have an honest moment
now that same question is being pointed
at Santos this is not about Democratic
or republican politics it's about making
sure that we have people of Integrity
holding public office and those who
engage in front modern lies being held
accountable
Robert Zimmerman staying above The Fray
there think of the things that he could
say but Mr Santos says that he has a
story to tell he'll tell it next week a
lot of people will be listening with
both ears to hear what he's how he
explains all of these discrepancies I
can't wait to hear it I'm fascinated by
this story too I think it could have
gone on this long it's a great story bar
who is George Santos yes who are you and
I said what was the first thing that
compounded the next and where where did
it start from yeah stay tuned next week
we may have some answers